Traductor: Paula Rodriguez
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
¿Cuántos de Uds. aquí presentes conocen
la relación entre este lápiz
y este cassette?
Probablemente, los de mi edad
o los mayores
lo ubiquen fácilmente.
Pero las personas que nacieron
en las últimas generaciones
quizás no lo tengan tan obvio.
Sin embargo, si les replanteo la pregunta,
y les digo cuántos de Uds. conocen
para qué sirven alguna
de estas dos aplicaciones,
tal vez sean las personas más jóvenes
las que sí sepan el uso de ellas.
Entonces, hoy vengo a compartir con Uds.
algunos de estos fuertes contrastes
que marcan tanto la generación
en la que estamos viviendo.
Básicamente, quiero comenzar
esta charla mostrando una película
de Charles Chaplin del año 1936,
para llevarlos a través
de un viaje en el tiempo
donde vamos a poder notar
algunos de estos fuertes contrastes
que les comento.
En esta película, se muestra
cómo un trabajador de la clase obrera
pierde su empleo debido
a la industrialización
y a la producción en serie
que se estaba llevando a cabo
en esos momentos.
Además, se vivía la Gran Depresión
de Estados Unidos.
Entonces, al ver esta película,
me he planteado una pregunta:
¿será que la tecnología nos juega
a favor o en contra,
con todos estos cambios
que vamos viviendo?
Para contextualizar
el concepto de 'cambio',
voy a utilizar la siguiente analogía.
Permítanme mostrarles esta imagen.
Como muchos de Uds. deben saber,
la materia tiene tres estados principales:
el estado sólido, el líquido y el gaseoso.
En estado sólido, las moléculas
se encuentran fuertemente unidas
y forman redes cristalinas generando
objetos obviamente sólidos,
que cuando presentan algún impacto,
no presentan deformación aparente.
A medida que se le aplica
temperatura o presión
a este objeto en estado sólido,
todos conocemos lo que
viene a continuación:
las moléculas comienzan a separarse
y se puede ver cómo el objeto
pasa a un estado líquido,
con la característica de que
se puede adaptar a cualquier entorno
que esté conteniendo esta sustancia.
Si se prolonga la aplicación
de temperatura o presión,
pues, básicamente, este líquido
pasa al estado gaseoso,
donde las moléculas principalmente
se expanden en el aire
y ya no tienen mucha
fuerza de atracción entre sí.
¿Por qué utilizo esta analogía?
Porque había un historiador...
perdón, sociólogo, llamado Zygmunt Bauman.
Él nos hablaba del concepto
de "modernidad líquida".
¿A qué se refiere con este concepto?
Él dice que, básicamente, hoy en día
los vínculos entre las personas
y las relaciones humanas
se están viendo fuertemente afectadas
debido a todos los cambios
que estamos viviendo
producto, justamente, de los avances
que se van dando en distintos campos,
como en este caso la tecnología.
Entonces, yo quisiera contarles
un poco mi vivencia personal
con respecto a todos estos cambios.
Cuando era muy pequeño, bastaba
con usar mi patineta o bicicleta
para salir con mis amigos
a pasarla bien al aire libre.
Nos trepábamos a los árboles,
jugábamos con nuestras hondas,
tirando piedras y demás.
Éramos unos traviesos.
Pero esto fue cambiando
a medida que fueron llegando
algunos dispositivos tecnológicos
a nuestra ciudad.
Por ejemplo, cuando tenía cinco años,
tuve mi primer Nintendo,
una consola que para mí
era fascinante en la época,
y podía juntarme con mis primos
o amigos del barrio
a jugar toda la tarde, y hacíamos
campeonatos de fútbol, y demás.
Más adelante, con la llegada de Internet,
aparecen los primeros café-Internet
en la ciudad, y esto va cambiando.
Entonces, con los amigos,
en vez de juntarnos en una casa
para compartir, nos íbamos
a estos cafés a hacer lo que se llamaban
las famosas "lechuceadas",
que era amanecerse toda la noche
jugando Medalla de Honor y distintos
juegos de matanzas y guerras.
Tal vez muchos de aquí
hayan vivido una buena lechuceada.
Más adelante, vemos que aparecen
consolas cada vez más inteligentes,
con el Internet de las cosas y,
prácticamente, todos los objetos
se empiezan a conectar a la Red.
Entonces, ni siquiera se vuelve necesario
ir a un lugar donde uno pueda jugar
con estos dispositivos,
sino que en tu propia casa
puedes estar conectado
con gente de todo el mundo,
mientras pasas un buen rato
haciendo lo que más te gusta.
Es el caso de mi hermano menor:
yo lo veo que se tira
varias amanecidas jugando con
gente de Irlanda, Alemania, Suecia.
Entonces, esto me lleva
a plantearme una incógnita:
¿será que la tecnología nos permite
conectarnos más con esa gente
que está lejos de nosotros,
pero nos está desconectando
de la gente que está cerca de nosotros?
Irónico, ¿no lo creen?
Cuando era joven, recuerdo que,
si algún profesor nos daba una tarea
en el colegio, teníamos que recurrir
solo a dos medios:
ir a la biblioteca municipal de la ciudad,
o ingresar a una computadora
y utilizar la Enciclopedia Encarta.
Obviamente, era una enciclopedia
que tenía muchísima información,
pero esta información era muy limitada.
Sin embargo, hoy en día
vemos plataformas muy poderosas,
como Wikipedia, donde uno,
al alcance de un solo clic,
puede encontrar una infinidad
de información
que antes no era ni siquiera imaginable.
¿Cuál es el gran problema de tener
un exceso de información?
Cosa que antes no se daba;
antes había una falta de información.
Pues, el problema es que
toda esta información
que tenemos a nuestra disposición
puede ser información que no es veraz.
Puede ser información alterada
por cualquier usuario.
De hecho, en Wikipedia cualquier persona
puede subir su contenido.
Cuando uno descarga información,
no sabe si esta información es real.
Hay una anécdota de cuando salió
la primera red social, llamada mIRC.
Recuerdo que yo iba a un café-Internet,
y chateaba con una chica.
Estaba completamente enamorado,
sin siquiera haberla conocido.
Había una buena conexión.
Salía del colegio, llegaba directo
a la computadora para conversar con ella,
hasta que llega un momento
en el que me dice:
¿qué te parece si nos conocemos
este fin de semana?
¡Perfecto!
Primera vez que nos íbamos
a ver en persona.
Había, como les digo, un fuerte vínculo
porque chateamos durante
más de tres meses.
Entonces, cuando llegamos a una heladería
para encontrarnos por primera vez,
una decepción total para ambos.
Yo no era lo que ella esperaba,
ella no era lo que yo esperaba.
Por eso les digo que no hay que creerse
todas las cosas que
uno encuentra en Internet.
Se dice que las personas que nacimos
en estas etapas de transición o cambio
somos personas muy flexibles,
nos adaptamos fácilmente a nuestro entorno
y a estos tiempos de cambio.
Por ejemplo, antes vivíamos en una era
donde los dispositivos eran analógicos,
mecánicos, y demás.
Hoy en día estamos pasando una transición
hacia lo que se conoce como
"revolución digital": la digitalización
de todos nuestros productos.
Por ejemplo, mi abuela tiene
muchos problemas cuando desea
hacer una llamada por teléfono.
Estaba muy acostumbrada a usar
los antiguos celulares.
Prefiere los grandes botones
con teclas y números
a una pantalla táctil.
Entonces, siempre necesita
la ayuda de los nietos
para poder usar este tipo de dispositivos.
Mi madre recién abrió un negocio
de venta de productos,
y no tenía mucho alcance a los clientes.
Entonces, me pide ayuda
para crear una página de Internet.
Le enseño cómo crear su página
y cómo contactar a posibles clientes.
Luego, cuando veo la página,
me doy cuenta de que solo tenía un like.
El like de mi madre.
Entonces, parte de esta enseñanza
era tratar de transmitirle
el buen uso de este tipo de tecnologías
que tenemos a nuestra disposición.
La última anécdota sería
el caso de mi padre,
quien, muchas veces cuando recibe
un mensaje por correo electrónico,
en vez de leerlo en la pantalla,
tiene la buena o mala costumbre
de imprimir los correos
para leerlos en papel.
Imagínense.
Para ir cerrando, quiero hablar
de uno de los más fuertes impactos
que está teniendo la tecnología hoy en día.
Tiene que ver con la pérdida de empleos
debido a la tecnificación del trabajo.
Se cree en muchos lugares del mundo,
sobre todo en países más desarrollados,
que las máquinas
nos están quitando empleo.
Esto se puede apreciar en estadísticas
de distintos países.
Es cierto, muchas máquinas
quitan el trabajo.
¿Por qué?
Porque las máquinas no se enferman,
no hay que asegurarlas,
trabajan 24 horas al día
y hacen un trabajo muy preciso.
A largo plazo, termina siendo
mucho más factible para una empresa,
sobre todo industrial,
contar con una máquina
que contar con muchas personas
en su cuerpo laboral.
Sin embargo, yo, como un fanático
y apasionado de la tecnología,
no vengo a compartir
esta parte triste y negativa
de cómo la tecnología nos quita el trabajo.
Al contrario, yo vengo a mostrarles
cómo la tecnología puede ser
una fuente de innovación y una herramienta
que nos puede permitir
generar nuevos vínculos
con las personas que nos rodean.
Quisiera compartir con Uds.
un caso, por ejemplo, de un amigo
que salió de la universidad
hace un par de años.
Él no tenía un trabajo previo,
entonces obviamente no tenía
un currículum aún muy amplio.
Iba tocando puerta por puerta
hasta encontrar algún trabajo posible.
Lo rechazaban, lo rechazaban
y lo rechazaban.
Entonces, se vio obligado a emprender
su propio negocio.
Vio que estaban proliferando en la ciudad
los negocios de comida informal,
llamados "food trucks",
los carritos de comida,
y se dedicó al diseño y la fabricación
de este tipo de carritos.
Hoy en día, le va bastante bien;
podemos ver que es un boom en la ciudad.
Construye y fabrica estos productos
hace ya más de dos años.
Otro caso son algunos amigos
que se ven obligados a vender
productos por Internet:
negocios de venta de flores,
de chocolates, de muebles, etcétera.
Y por último, el caso de un familiar
muy cercano que perdió su empleo
hace seis meses y, hasta el día de hoy,
le es muy difícil encontrar
un nuevo trabajo o fuente laboral,
precisamente porque se ha desactualizado,
producto de todos estos rápidos cambios.
Hoy en día, prácticamente
no es una persona empleable,
porque no cuenta con
este tipo de conocimientos
en el manejo de distintas
herramientas digitales y tecnológicas.
Entonces, quisiera decirles lo siguiente.
Vamos a usar una última escena
de la película de Charles Chaplin,
donde se puede ver cómo la novia
o la chica con la que salía Chaplin
durante la película
prácticamente está desahuciada,
no quiere salir adelante,
y le dice que no vale la pena.
Él, con una actitud muy positiva, le dice:
¡No! ¡Vamos adelante!
Podemos salir adelante juntos.
Yo quiero, con esa misma actitud,
invitar a todos a plantearnos
la siguiente pregunta:
¿cómo podemos hacer
para enfrentarnos a un futuro
cada vez más incierto
y a todos estos cambios
que se siguen viniendo más adelante?
Pues, la respuesta no la tengo yo.
Pero lo que sí les puedo asegurar,
para que no pasemos
de una sociedad líquida a
una sociedad prácticamente gaseosa,
es que utilicemos las tecnologías
para que jueguen a nuestro favor,
generando conexiones entre
las personas que más queremos,
generando conocimiento,
compartiendo el conocimiento
y, además, vinculándonos más
con nuestros seres queridos.
Como les decía, las personas mayores
a veces se sienten vulnerables,
no nos quieren pedir ayuda a la hora
de trabajar con estas herramientas,
pero nosotros, como
embajadores de la tecnología,
los jóvenes de hoy en día,
tenemos la responsabilidad y el deber
de generar y compartir este conocimiento.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)